so this is sort of a quick bookend to
our Iran story
it appears that Eric Trump Donald
Trump's son knew in advance about the
assassination that was carried out
illegally without congressional approval
of the Iranian codes leader Kasim
Soleimani of course the assassination
took place on January 2nd 2020 but just
a couple of days prior in the last 12
hours really the last eight nine hours
of 2019 on December 31st
Eric Trump tweeted quote bout to open up
a big old can of whoop-ass hashtag don't
mess with the best hashtag USA USA USA
this is believed now in retrospect to be
a clear reference to knowledge that Eric
Trump had of the upcoming unauthorized
assassination by the Trump
administration of Iranian codes leader
Kasim soleimani now Eric Trump since
this came to light that wait a second a
whole bunch of people who should have
been briefed weren't briefed how did
Eric Trump know about this Eric Trump
has since deleted the tweet because it
became clear that Donald Trump did not
seek congressional authorization the
assassination is likely illegal Congress
didn't know and it seems that Donald
Trump's son unelected not a government
employee doesn't have the clearance to
know about this it seems that Eric Trump
knew about this in advance here's a
quote from Heather Cox Richardson a
historian who's been covering this who
said quote apparently the gang of eight
was not briefed Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer was not told
although McConnell's spokesman refused
to comment on whether or not he meaning
mcconnell was briefed and she goes on to
say Eric trump who holds no security
clearance might have been briefed on
December 31st he tweeted bout to open up
a big old can of whoop-ass the tweet has
now been deleted I will actually go even
further now with the 20/20 hindsight
knowing what took place in Iraq over the
last 24 hours a couple of weeks ago
December 18th it was reported that five
top Pentagon
officials had resigned in a seven day
period it was weird at the time we
didn't know you know five top Pentagon
officials resigning in seven days
doesn't really make sense the idea now
that we are increasingly thinking as the
explanation for this is that the plan
was starting to develop at that point in
time in the second half early in the
second half of December these five key
Pentagon officials were against this
completely immoral arguably illegal
assassination and that they resigned
will we ever know the full truth of who
knew when and why they resigned and and
the lack of proper handling of sensitive
information here probably not but this
thinks too high heaven as usual it seems
that Donald Trump is being totally
careless with his handling of sensitive
information if indeed his son Eric Trump
knew in advance about what was going on
and then of course there is the
political side of Donald Trump for years
saying hey Barack Obama you need
congressional approval the president
can't do this the president can't strike
there without congressional approval
Donald Trump letting Eric Trump know but
not letting the gang of eight know not
letting congressional leadership know
not actually going and seeking approval
for doing this it's projection it's
backwards it's all a tactic to try to
get himself reelected in 2020 and it
really pains me to say it but it might
work it might work if the last three
years of observing how trumpets have
been successfully propagandized to and
gas-lit willingly to try to placate
their cognitive dissonance with donald
trump if that's any indication this may
actually work and we are increasingly
driving towards war with iran it was
Hillary remember it was Hillary that was
going to get us into Wars into military
conflicts unauthorized erratic
bloodthirsty seems like that was all
projection let me know what you think it
is these are these are scary and
depressing times leave a comment if
you're watching on youtube or send me a
tweet on twitter at deep hackman we'll
take a break
much to discuss on today's program